a new annual report released this
morning reveals the top
global risks for 2021. every year
eurasia group that's a political risk
research and consulting firm
ranks the top 10 geopolitical risks that
we are likely to face
in the new year and the report says
let's go in reverse order the third
greatest risk is
climate change the second is the
long-term effects of the corona virus
pandemic
and it says that the greatest risk is
political polarization right here in
america and the ways it could affect joe
biden's presidency
ian bremmer is the president and founder
of eurasia group and he joins us now ian
good morning to you
uh so these risks as you point out in
the report uh
are based on the size the imminence and
the likelihood of them happening
typically uh the information is focused
toward businesses maybe even governments
but let's try to boil it down for people
uh in their everyday lives because there
are concerns there as well and i want to
begin there
you say that joe biden's presidency will
be a quote asterisk
presidency the first of its kind what do
you mean
well like a-rod or roger clemens or
barry bonds you put an asterisk after it
and you say oh that record doesn't count
you got almost half of the country
that's going to see
joe biden as not a legitimate president
this is playing out right now
with i mean not just president trump but
you've got ted cruz and a majority of
republican elected officials
in the senate and the house that are
saying that they're going to vote
against
the will of the people the will of the
electors in the united states that's
that's unprecedented we've never had
that happen before
and this is a time when you really need
the u.s
government to be functioning well
because we have this massive crisis you
have a need for the government to
legislate to respond
to deal with the needs of the average
american
the country's not been this politically
divided in our lifetimes
um and it's not been this economically
unequal and that that really given the
size of the u.s economy globally
it's impossible not to have that as risk
number one this year
yeah you say in the report that we are
the most uh powerful but also divided
and unequal country on earth or
certainly among the industrialized
western democracies
this is the second year in a row that
america or something happening in
america has occupied the top position
the top risk in the world
what does that say about the trajectory
of our country
well and i started the firm back in 1998
and the u.s had never been
uh on top before and and that's because
historically political institutions in
the united states
were stronger they were seen as much
more legitimate
but when you think about um the ability
of the americans to stand
up for our system the average american
does
indeed think um that the that the
institutions are increasingly
rigged against them that representative
democracy doesn't work i mean i i would
make the argument today that the average
chinese believes more in the china dream
because of the expanse of the middle
class there than the average american
believes in the american dream that
doesn't mean that people want to live in
china
they much rather live in the united
states but
no one around the world looks at the us
and says i wish my political system
would run like that and and that
undermines the ability of the united
states to provide
leadership on trade or to lead by
example
around the world it makes life a lot a
lot more difficult for those of us
those of us here ian i want to dig a
little bit more deeply into the report
number six on your top ten list of risk
global data reckoning you mentioned
something there about
foreign adversaries getting personal
data on americans or people in other
countries
and then blackmailing can you expand on
that
sure i mean what we know is that over
the course of this last
year uh the russian government has
been involved been inside of uh hundreds
of institutions both the u.s
government as well as private sector and
were grabbing all of that data we don't
know
what they're planning on doing with it
but we know that they're vastly
adversarial
to the interests of the united states
our citizens uh
and our government and you think it
could result in we're facing a lot of
of course of course i mean there's a
reason why when you remember grindr
that app that allowed the men to hook up
or in the united states and the chinese
government was the chinese company was
going to buy it
and we stopped them for national
security purposes because there was a
feeling that a lot of people in congress
that might be on that app for example we
don't want the chinese government having
that data
when a foreign adversary gets private
data that's a problem right we don't
want that yeah you also mention
uh in a section on cyber security that
china has a
super computer that may make eventually
passwords obsolete we don't have much
time but that worried me
well the fact that quantum computing a
lot of people in ai do believe that that
has the potential to get rid of all uh
crypto
security and the the fact of the matter
is there are two
technology superpowers in the world
today one is the us
one is china we as americans are not
used to having parody with another big
country out there
it's going to be a challenge for people
need to be concerned all right ian
bremmer thank you very much we
appreciate it
we're worried we'll be right back you're
watching cbs this morning